financial donations to Ohio's Athens
County Food Pantry have now topped
$400,000 after a Heisman Trophy winner
Joe borough used his acceptance speech
to focus on hunger in the area where he
grew up I'm up here for all of those all
those kids in Athens and in Athens
County that you know go home to not a
lot of food on the table hungry after
school and you guys can be up here too
but for more than 34 million Americans
it's food stamps not fundraisers that
help them survive now there's concern
proposed changes in that federal program
could drastically cut those benefits the
Trump administration says it wants to
reduce waste Adriana Diaz is at a food
bank just outside Minneapolis in Rihanna
what are we learning well Anthony the
Department of Agriculture which operates
the program declined our request for an
on-camera interview but yesterday they
told us that these proposed changes are
to quote ensure that the SNAP program
which is the food stamp program is there
for those in need
they want to make sure that food stamp
recipients who can work do work
especially given near record low
unemployment but families are still
worried after patience Coley and John's
Pinellas rented nearly doubled they had
to move out and into their car with
their toddler and teenager and you would
eat in here sleep in here they see the
stress and anxiety caused patients to go
on medical leave leaving the family on
one income like a snowball effect in the
breaks called in your alternator goes
and you trying to catch a break it
survived in part thanks to food stamps
under the government's Supplemental
Nutrition Assistance Program known as
snap the average recipient gets about
127 dollars a month that's a dollar 40 a
meal three meals a day but an estimated
3.7 million Americans could lose their
benefits next year if the government
implements three proposed changes
removing automatic enrollment for
families who first qualify for other
government benefits reducing how
people can deduct for utilities like
heat and requiring more able-bodied
adults to work at least 20 hours a week
to receive benefits this last proposal
has already been finalized and will be
implemented in April they're gonna need
more help from us
Alison O'Toole runs Second Harvest
Heartland the country's second largest
food bank we have seen more visits than
ever before state says the economy
hasn't recovered in every every place
and we provide
we're very proud of that but we'd love
to go to business through another
government program patience and John
found a house they can afford they plan
to move this week and will not qualify
for snap once patient starts working but
they still hope the program continues
part of the reason why the government is
making these changes to snap is because
they say the economy is doing great
unemployment is so low that a lot of
people should be able to work who aren't
working where is the unemployment so
they'll know that everyone's working
doing anything to the snap you're gonna
make the poor similar changes to the
food stamp program were proposed in last
year's farm bill but left out of the
final law so USDA is now making these
changes on its own 24 states have urged
the government to reconsider and some
jurisdictions are considering legal
action all right thank you very much
Adriana it's so important to show that
there are real people by a lot of people
the nationally may be good but that is
not equally shared the typical family is
actually poor today than they were
before the financial crisis in 2008 and
there's some of the money is that is
it's critical for those facts absolutely
and it's accurate in fact the the
Department of Agriculture says 99%
accuracy in making sure that the people
who are getting the money are the right
people they are eligible it's not fraud
yeah that was a good example of why that
program matters thank you very much
again Adriana
you